Це оперативне відео Патрульної поліції Києва.
Заступник міністра з питань стратегічних галузей промисловості Віталій Немілостівий
керував авто у нетверезому стані та розвернувся через подвійну суцільну лінію.
Я вам кажу, як на духу. Враховуючи час, я відпустив водія.
Я, випивши, сів за кермо. Я винен. Питань нема.
Я розвернувся там на зустрічній. Поїхав сюди.
Мене зараз Патрульна поліція зупинила. Я зупинився. Показав свої документи. Вибачився.
Після розголосу у пресі уряд вже звільнив його з посади.
Поліція зупинила нетверезого чиновника, фактично реагуючи на порушення ним правил дорожнього руху.
Однак найближчим часом Верховна Рада збирається розглянути законопроєкт,
який передбачає право Патрульної поліції робити раптові перевірки водіїв на стан алкогольного сп'яніння.
Наразі це не дозволено робити. Таким чином влада вчергове прагне додатковими заходами підвищити безпеку дорожнього руху.
Досі статистика ДТП в Україні з року в рік залишаєтся невтішною.
Минулого року побільшало не лише аварій, а і смертей на українських дорогах.
У 2020 році загинули понад три з половиною тисячі людей.
Причому найбільше - 1198 смертей - це наїзд на пішохода.
Друга головна причина -  зіткнення автівок - 1158 жертв.
Зросло і число смертельних наїздів на велосипедистів. Загинули 235 осіб.
Як стверджують у поліції, в місцях встановлення камер фотовідеофіксації швидкості аварійність суттєво знизилася,
подекуди сталося навіть майже втричі менше ДТП.
Але перевищення безпечної швидкості залишається головною причиною смертельних аварій.
Причому з величезним відривом - 1776 жертв.
Це втричі більше, ніж під час порушення правил маневрування і аж у 17 разів більше,
ніж через керування автівкою у стані сп’яніння.
За логікою ця статистика мала б бути іншою. Адже 2020-ий - особливий рік:
через пандемію коронавірусу та зменшення активності населення чимало людей працювали з дому
та не їздили на роботу. Наприклад, у Німеччині минулого року було менше смертельних ДТП.
За даними Федерального статистичного відомства ФРН, в період з березня по червень минулого року,
тобто коли був локдаун, на німецьких дорогах загинули 880 людей.
Це майже на вісімнадцять відсотків менше, ніж у відповідний період роком раніше.
Загалом же, за оцінками експертів, 2020 рік став роком з найменшою кількістю загиблих в ДТП у Німеччині
від початку ведення статистики, тобто з 1953 року.
Чому ж в Україні сталося навпаки?
За словами опитаних DW експертів, з одного боку, пандемія спонукала людей
пересісти з громадського транспорту на власний.
Відповідно збільшилася кількість автівок на дорогах у містах.
А з іншого боку, в певні періоди карантину було менше машин, зокрема, на міжміських дорогах -
це надихало деяких водіїв перевищувати швидкість, що, власне, і є головною причиною смертельних аварій минулого року.
Водночас, за словами юриста Вадима Володарського, який спеціалізується на дорожньому русі,
статистика щодо причин аварійності в Україні часто викривлена,
відсоток ДТП, які сталися через перевищення швидкості, завищений.
Натомість нехтування пішоходами і велосипедистами правил дорожнього руху,
зокрема відсутність одягу із світловідвертаючими елементами або ліхтарів на велосипедах не завжди береться до уваги.
Так само, як і неналежний стан доріг, за що дуже рідко когось притягають до відповідальності.
За словами експерта, встановлення камер фотовідеофіксації швидкості
саме по собі не призводить до істотного зниження аварійності.
Водії знають, де вони встановлені, проїжджають "проблемне" місце і далі знову розганяються.
Ще одна причина трагічних ДТП - відсутність культури безпечного водіння.
Українські водії та їхні пасажири нерідко нехтують необхідністю пристібатися ременями безпеки.
А велосипедисти не завжди одягають захисні шоломи.
Крім того, багато водіїв не пам’ятають, як надавати першу допомогу, тому смертельно поранені учасники ДТП
просто не доживають до приїзду "швидкої".
За даними організації World life expectancy, у світі щороку в ДТП
гине понад один мільйон триста тисяч людей.
У європейському регіоні Україна серед антилідерів.
Її випереджають лише Албанія, Боснія і Герцеговина та Білорусь.
Найкраща ж ситуація у Швеції та Швейцарії.
У Росії ж, яка знаходиться в регіоні Азія, показник майже вдвічі гірший, ніж в Україні.
Якщо порінювати з тим, що було на українських дорогах понад 10 років тому,
коли, приміром, 2007-го загинуло понад 9 з половиною тисяч людей,
нині ситуація покращилася. І в останні п’ять років смертність на дорогах в Україні
залишається приблизно на одному рівні - до трьох з половиною тисяч жертв щороку.
І лише 2020-го, попри локдаун, цей показник дещо збільшився.